more than 300 000 students are back in
school all across clark county but many
parents are really unsure if their child
is ready for the challenge of a new
school year after last year's distance
learning bianca holman explains the
impact of the covid slide and what
parents can do to help she had
difficulty being able to
determine
what tasks needed to be done on a daily
basis it was hard like most parents
across the valley edna enyang struggled
to help get her child through class
online during the pandemic for many
students they were frustrated learning
new math topics reading concepts or
completing science projects i did not
like it at all it was hard
and challenging this school year is like
no other because on top of the summer
slide which is the loss of skills kids
picked up during the previous school
year now there's the covet slide with
covert that slide has been accelerated
exponentially because not only
did they
experience not being in school for a
much extended period of time even when
they had the remote learning
opportunities it really didn't make up
for being in school academic experts at
huntington learning center say kids are
coming in two years behind first graders
unable to read or kindergarteners who
don't know the alphabet the early years
are pivotal we get a lot of third
graders in here who
they can read and they read very fast
but then you ask them the comprehension
questions they have no idea what they
read it's going to take
that
stress off of you because as parents we
have so many other responsibilities and
there's no way that we can wear
several hats i mean we try but we don't
do as good of a job and hackman also
says tutoring can help a child's
emotional health academic success can
relieve the anxiety helping to build
their self-confidence for gabriella the
sessions have made a difference now
she's the one helping classmates it's
nice because it's passing kindness to
another bianca holman 8 news now